Metal Gear Survive will deliver the latest gameplay video of Metal Gear Survive by playing tgs 2016.
Metal Gear survive
will progress the story by clearing the mission like Metal Gear Solid 5 Phantom Pain
This time it is a part of it  Katsu
Kaishu Metal Gear survive is a story about mother-based soldiers who have been sent to another
world and survive to return to the original world.
They collect materials, make tools,
and use everything to find a way to return to the original world.
The purpose of this mission is to install a transmitter at the origin of a special worm hole
and send the old Lancy Bone to the
destination.  Mark
This time I will be divided into two teams and will be appointed.
Thank you for being 5th place.
Wow, in the future, it will be possible to efficiently collect materials by doing
this.  There is an enemy to do. The
head is missing. The moderator looks bad. It
's a national danger to face multiple enemies from the front.
Let's use the
artificial bait.
Is a weakness of creatures.
You can kill them instantly if you destroy them. In
Metal Gear Survive, you can also use enemy creatures as a material.
Collect the material inside the building
dd Let's get rid of the creature in front of the mouth
in cooperation with allies
8 minutes
Sling shot is effective in such a situation
You can take a few seconds if you hit the corner with a surprise
It's
possible to use the knowledge to defeat the enemy in this way-
it was useful after collecting the material
tan tan
What is the leading team in the base action?
It's a strategy while collecting team materials
. There are creatures. Go unnoticed. It's a creature in
front.
Car
Arkan Ejaculation It seems that my leg was injured
. Various disadvantages occur depending on the type of fur.
It is not possible to collect the places where the item is needed and make an item.
It's a continuation of three types of treatments that are extremely important in the mission capture of Metal
Gear Survival. The
destination is in front of you, but some creatures are blocking the way.
I wonder if they have been blown into this world. They
are four of the same drifters.
Here is a collection to help him. 2
This is a multiplayer battle mode of mgs 5.
Awaken me, by the
way, the masses aren't coming to this world every day.
I'm sorry, but after a while, I'm
drawn to the voice of the sheep and the creatures gathered in one place.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
let him relax at the booth camp
That's the destination this time
To safely install a transmitter with a lot of enemies you have to eliminate everything
Send a sign of a little gathering with a marker that doesn't become a sign of a
large gathering. It's a rush to join.
From now on, the operation will proceed to the second stage. The
transmission will shift from the infiltration mission so far to the defense mission that protects the transmitter from the enemy's attack
.  Outgoing rounds
Watch out for the surroundings from a good view.
Cardboard appears from the wormhole.
Recovery position
Yes
, one of my friends is heading
to secure it.
It's been 9 years since I've been
sending a signal. It's a quick start while sending a signal.
You can freely choose and install the best place for
tar.
What about the situation of other friends?
They are friends who are heading for the collection of cardboard.
During the mission, you can not only fight but also divide various roles like this.
It seems that the prepared material is available
car
wh
I was able to protect it safely,
so the
next profit is imminent.
Harden your defense.
Oh, it's a
craft stand.
You can craft it even during a mission if you collect materials. Craft a
barricade.
It's
a line barricade that seems to have started.
You can damage it when you touch it.
Install a face
. Basic defense that has both width and
height.  It's Risa Yeah Yeah Yeah
me My
best friend from the window
me
me It's
also a target from here
Set up a marker and let your friends know
wh
me wh  I wonder if the
material recovery cucumber was discovered me
Yeah yeah yeah
car
Ran and I was able to repel the
next shuri I'm going
to craft a machine gun with the material obtained from the secured cardboard
me
This is a wide range  It became possible to cover
car
tee
wh I was approaching from the other side
car car
This time there are a lot of enemies It's a
fierce battle
There seems to be durability against weight in the phase
It doesn't seem to last long
car
Yeah Yeah Yeah
The number of weapons is increasing steadily This is a barricade
fence has been destroyed A
large number of enemies are rushing in and can't be prevented
Yeah Yeah Yeah
Unfortunately it's a
mission failure to abolish
Metal  Gear survive tgs 2016 Pu 0 day
This time the
mission was unfortunately unsuccessful, but I think you could see a part of the charm of the cooperative mission. When
various other missions and stages appear in Metal Gear Survival,
they  Thank you for your expectations for future information.
Thank you for watching until the end.